it happened long before I was born  clandestine government testing on the  lunar surface caused the moon to split  creating a massive earthquake they  called it the shattering and it nearly  cracked our world into the ground broke  oceans boiled  and gravity never went back to normal  but we rebuilt memories of the old world  drifted into the past and humanity  turned its gaze forward  it came back stronger than ever and for  a while things were good then came the  gangs gravity manipulation and  supplement use led to near superhuman  abilities  cartel's from around the world unified  have formed the breakers but 2105 their  empire expanded on the US soil flooding  the streets with narcotics and war law  enforcement agencies were unified to  keep the peace Sam and I signed up on  the first day  there's no sitting on the sidelines not  anymore you either uphold the law or you  break it  you